let's deal with a good bad and ugly so
i've got a bunch of notes over here so i
can expand a little bit
on these talking points good uh increase
lean muscle mass you're going to burn
fat testosterone burns fat
okay one of the things a lot of guys
notice if they come in
at six foot two 250 pounds and they're
carrying a lot of belly fat
uh they got maybe a little bit of man
boobs and stuff like that
like not even working out alone and just
administering uh therapeutic dosages of
testosterone
will actually burn belly fat believe it
or not so a lot of guys will notice that
there's a reduction in um you know like
pear-shaped bodies if they you know if
they're storing a lot of fat around
their waist
and you'll naturally put on a little bit
more muscle now if you work out
i don't know why you would go on trt and
not
lift weights it's good from
there's no downside to lifting weights
at all it's all upside it's it's good
for your brain it's good for your body
having lean muscle tissue on your body
is healthy
um it's it's gonna mean you've got a
better immune system you've got more
bone density when you're on
healthy levels of testosterone uh it's
cardio protective it's neuroprotective
you can also look at other compounds too
i know that there's
clinics in the us which will also
prescribe things like deca durabalan
and anavar deca is a wonderful compound
if you have bad
joints there's some downsides to it so
you've got to do your homework on it you
can end up with
ed conditions if you're taking too much
of it or if you're prolactin spikes
these are all things that you should
learn about and ask your doctor about
but there's other compounds which
they'll offer you as well which aren't
part of testosterone replacement therapy
or bioidentical
but they can offer benefits you can also
go outside of it once you understand
how this works and how administration
and how dosaging works
and you can look at other useful
compounds like primobolin
you may have a guy that does some home
brewing that you know can hook you up
with something
those are things that you can you know
consider that are outside of the
standard protocol
which will potentially offer a better
quality of life depending on what your
goals and
and and your objectives are uh back to
the good
uh improved libido improved uh sexual
function
uh you stay on top of frequent blood
work so all your health markers
uh prostate markers um blood lipids
uh white blood cell count red blood cell
counts your
hemoglobin your hematocrit all that
stuff productivity goes up
like i said earlier you know i make more
money uh
testosterone makes effort feel good
again i'm gonna echo what huberman said
i totally agree it's it's prob it's
probably the best way to sum it up
uh the bad needles for life um
you're gonna be poking your body with if
you're smart that
not this the freaking harpoon this is
what this is what most places will give
you which will make it
hard annoying lame and frustrating get
this it makes it more easy
it's far easier to backfill and
administer every other day it's a simple
process
but you're gonna be doing it for the
rest of your life if if you want to stay
on it
now there's other ways to deliver it to
your body like i said there's
um pellets which i don't think are a
great idea there's nasal sprays which
have quite a few downsides and they're
quite expensive there's
um dissolving lozenges you know you can
put on your tongue
there's some problems with that and
they're more expensive um
what else do they got they got
compounding creams and gels the gels
aren't the greatest ones like the cookie
cutter ones if you have a pharmacy that
can compound a cream
at 200 milligrams per milliliter um
jay campbell uh i think he invented this
protocol i don't know maybe maybe not
but basically
he was on pins for his entire life since
he started uh since the basketball
injury and started to use compounded
creams and basically he found that his
levels stayed the same
as a therapeutic administration with
needles
with a compounded cream the problem with
that though is you have to administer
the cream on your scrotum
which means you gotta do manscaping on a
regular basis and you have to make sure
that you're putting the cream on twice a
day
so somewhat of an inconvenience because
you've got to walk around
you know commando style while the cream
is getting absorbed through your scrotum
apparently that's the best place to put
it put it it's where you'll get the best
roi
on it so there's that downside of you
you know you want to make sure that it
absorbs before you put on clothing you
want to make sure it doesn't get on
anybody
he did say that there's a bit of a bump
in um
uh sexual function because of dht so
uh because of the location and because
of its cream um
if you're having issues with libido
a cream might be more useful a compound
or cream so there's that to consider as
well
uh back to the bad uh following
so delivery methods we talked about that
uh diligence schedule you got to follow
it i mean
if you take days off you're not going to
feel good you've
you've got to follow it to a t it's like
brushing your teeth flossing your teeth
you can't take days off you can but
you're not going to feel good so you
have to stick to the schedule
so i think it's really important that if
you're going to do this you know
you make it a habit it's like at this
time every day or you do it while you're
brushing your teeth or after you're
brushing your teeth or after your shower
or something like that you just
insert it into your schedule and it's
like two or three more minutes out of
your day doing something that improves
your quality of life
um your testicles will atrophy so
uh that's something that somebody
brought up earlier about hcg human
chorionic gynotropin i started out
just on testosterone and by about week
three um
my testing just started to hurt like
they were aching and i'm like what the
hell and i call the doctor's office and
he goes yeah they're starting to atrophy
it was totally normal that you know the
pain is going to go away after a while
it's going to be fine
and to be honest i was like no this
sucks um
give me the hcg hcg is more expensive
it's it's about 180 bucks
per vial and it lasts about as long as
your testosterone so it's a lot more
expensive
and all that does is it makes sure that
your body
is still producing it's that your
testicles still produce testosterone
so hcg i'm going to screw up the entire
pathway obviously because i'm not an
expert on this
but um there's receptors in your body i
think they're called
lh receptors or luteinizing hormone or
fh receptors i might be butchering it
but
they're all throughout your body so one
of the things that some guys notice when
they just go on t
is when that production disappears and
those receptors don't get what they need
which you get with hcg
plus you get your own uh endogenous
production
is they don't feel so good or they don't
have the same quality sex that they had
or
um because you're bought your test your
testicles atrophy because your testicles
atrophy
um the how can i put this pleasantly
the volume is not as large as it used to
be
you know what i'm saying okay so there's
that to consider personally i feel
better
on t and hcg combined that's what i use
so
day one will be t day two will be hcg
and then you just keep repeating so
every day there's a pin very simple
takes two three
uh minutes not that big of a deal hcg is
very simple to administer it's actually
easier because it's water based
so it's easier to push through the pin
and you can put it anywhere it can go
into belly fat which is where i usually
put it so i usually do
hcg in the belly fat and i do the tee
shots into the
ventral glute if you want to know how to
do that just search
how to inject in the ventral glute it
shows you where the location is and how
to do it you'll find
videos bad um some guys experience more
body hair and acne i
i probably have a little bit more body
hair
maybe slightly more acne in the winter
time in the summertime
i don't get any acne whatsoever in the
summertime because i'm out in the sun
i'm on a boat i'm swimming at the pool
whatever
all you need to do is apply some
sunshine to your body and you don't get
any acne
okay for some guys they'll they'll get
really bad
back knee which is what they'll come you
know complain about
but it's probably because their dose is
way too high and uh
you know they're on the cookie cutter
200 milligram you know script which
is way too high causes huge bolus spikes
and then you know they end up with all
kinds of you know
side effects which are not desirable so
doing
smaller regular dosages eliminates that
problem completely or it did for me
anyway
bad is cost shit's not free but
anything that's worthwhile is never free
there's always a cost associated to it
you want to eat quality food it's going
to cost you money you want to eat
you know organic vegetables it's going
to cost you slightly more money so
um yeah it's going to cost you more
money so like what's the problem you're
a guy you should be chasing excellence
you should be okay with that cost maybe
maybe you've got an insurance
uh provider that will take care of it
for you but again it's not free
managing injection sites some people are
prone to
post injection pain or bruising i've
never had a problem with pip
or bruising myself i've seen some guys
complain about it
it's mostly because again it's a shitty
protocol from their doctor's office
one of the common injection sites that
i've seen a lot of guys get from the
doctor's office is in their quads
and if you go stick an inch and a half
needle
into your quad like picture an inch and
a half needle into your quad which by
the way has a lot of nerve endings
and there's some big ass um uh
veins in there carrying a lot of blood
to different parts of your body
if you hit one of those you're going to
hit the roof so
a lot of guys end up with problems like
bruising or extreme pain just because
the doctor's office says inject it into
your quads
you can put it pretty much anywhere in
your body it doesn't have to be
your quads or your glutes there's
multiple injection sites i've seen guys
say they'll do shoulder pec pec shoulder
and they'll just rotate that way you
know throughout the week
that may not be a plausible sight for
some people because they don't have pecs
like you actually have to have
muscle tissue on your chest because if
you don't have anything in your like
bird cage sort of chest and it's just
rip showing you've got nothing to inject
it to so that's not a plausible sight
so these are things that you have to
manage so i suppose it's one of the bad
things but just understand you know like
it is what it is uh let's talk about the
ugly
uh other compounds so i talked earlier
about the introduction of other
compounds like deca primobolan anavar
stuff like that
uh they can be abused misused or
faked okay i'll be honest with you i've
i've been down to mexico
and everything is over the counter there
you can go down to a pharmacy just
outside of the resort
you can get uh sustanon 250 you can get
deca derbal and you can get proviron you
can get
pretty much everything under the sun um
if it's got things like
bayer on it you know it's it's it's
actual pharmaceutical grade but there's
some there that could be faked
um you don't know what you're getting
dosed sometimes you can get out of hand
and you're like oh yeah you know all the
shit's going on let's put some deca and
we'll mix in some of this
and it spikes your levels like way off
the chart and
you're not managing things properly so
sometimes
part of the ugly can be you you know
you're like oh well this
turns my this turns my life up to 11. so
what happens if we add some of this and
add a little bit of this
and we turn this up to 17 right um
you can run into problems if you don't
know what you're doing so i would
encourage you guys if you're gonna apply
other compounds
or use it more for athletic purposes and
results beyond just their
just beyond therapeutic usages you
better know what you're doing
you could be tempted to do things that
might ruin your health or your organ so
if you're using huge dosages because you
think it's going to make you grow more
muscle
or you know for whatever reason you
can put your organs at risk um there's a
reason why you see some of these
bodybuilders
just drop dead you know at some point in
their life who was it um
rich uh piana huge dude um he
basically dropped dead when his
girlfriend was giving him a haircut at
like 43.
okay but i mean dude looked like he was
300 pounds
freaking monster you know you can go
look him up um
your organs can shut down one of the um
studies that so let me talk about some
really good resources so i'd recommend
that you guys take a look at a couple of
different channels here let me
actually i'm not going to pull them up
so just make notes of this a really good
resource on youtube is a channel called
vigorous steve
um he's a dutch guy that lives in
thailand
very very smart dude i've been watching
him for a while
i contacted him recently and i'm hoping
to have him on for a plane to win very
soon uh to talk about stuff like this in
detail
another channel um is a guy called leo
and longevity
and um i don't know where he's located
he's got an interesting accent i think
he's persian or greek maybe i'm not sure
but um you can check him out as well
he's not on t
and um he he prefers not to run it
he was a big time power lifter and
basically walked away from it and he's
very interested in
what it can do and how he can help out
his clients and stuff like that again
none of these guys are doctors but
it's like what they've made their life
and it's really interesting to see the
level of commitment
and time that they spend putting out
videos
very well researched videos on on topics
that anything from
building muscle losing fat sexual
function
cognitive function protecting different
organs in your body if you've got issues
with them like one of the things that i
came across was a study where
they basically castrated rats and they
found that
by lowering androgens in their body so
there's
no testosterone production whatsoever
because when you castrate you know the
gonads and there's no testosterone
production um endogenously
organ health improved so testosterone
can
shorten the life of your organs if
you're abusing it
your kidneys will last longer so you
know these are all things to consider
when you go on trt
i'm of the camp that you want to stay
around the therapeutic dose
maybe you might want to play with some
other compounds i've used prima ball and
i've used that
i've used proviron i've used um susan on
250.
i've tried out a bunch of stuff and i'll
be honest with you the juice ain't
really worth the squeeze
i've never tried things like uh like
crazy compounds like uh
trenbolone or um like uh
what's some of the orals which are very
liver toxic i can't remember what they
are but
i've stayed away from anything that's
liver toxic i've stayed mostly with
either injectables or anything that's
oral that's not liver toxic
um so you have to be very careful so you
got to do your study so that's one of
the things you have to consider for the
ugly uh
most doctors even trt clinics don't know
what the hell they're doing
and i'll give you a very good example
there's a
lab test which is called egfr
and if you have an athletic build like i
do and
they want to test your kidney health
egfr is the standard test which will
test your kidney health
my lab started to come back saying that
i was having kidney problems and i'm
like what the hell like i don't i don't
drink
i don't smoke you know i've got a clean
diet yes i'm on trt
why is my egfr you know basically
screwed up and i came across this video
and here's another very good resource
for you which
i'm gonna be honest with you he's kind
of transitions his channel now
there's a guy named derek from a channel
called more plates more dates
and most of his videos in the past were
more like vigorous steve's now he's kind
of gone more to the clickbaity stuff
where
he gets a lot more views but it's not as
useful as far as the data that you get
but
a lot of his older videos i came across
one that was talking about
kidney tests and rather than using the
egfr you use one called chrostatincy
which is a more accurate evaluation of
your kidney health especially if you
have an athletic build so
these are all things that i didn't know
myself and had i relied on my doctor
i would have probably thought at the
time that there was something wrong with
my kidneys or they were gonna fail or
something like that
but following up and getting the
information from a smart guy that knows
what he's talking about that takes
actual research studies and presents it
to his audience
like damn that makes sense now okay so i
got some clarity on that so
these are all things that you've got to
learn when you get into this you really
can't trust doctors you've got to stay
on top of everything
uh ugly there's a cost uh it's not
available in every country i've got
friends of mine
around the world from my community that
they're in different country like
it's not available they will not
prescribe it they basically just say
you're fine one of the things that guys
will get so
you're not going to get help from your
doctor from your family doctor if you
say test
you know check my blood labs let's see
what my testosterone looks like and if
it comes back and it's like
if the range is 200 or 400 or something
like that
and you're at 225 they're going to say
oh yeah you're in normal ranges
but you could be 43 you're not getting
morning wood anymore you've got no
libido you're getting fat your muscles
wasting you can't focus
you got a lot of brain fog even though
you know it says normal ranges it's like
you know
when kids can't slam dunk the basketball
all they do is they lower the net
and that's what they've done with
testosterone levels over the years
because they really want you sick and
weak as men in society
so most family doctors be like no you're
fine you know you're you're in the
normal ranges based on you know what the
charts say
doesn't matter if you feel like and
you have all the symptoms of low t
i would say go to a testosterone
replacement clinic you have to google it
look
look up hrt hormone replacement therapy
look up
trt testosterone replacement therapy
look up tot
testosterone optimization therapy
there's different language that they use
in different parts of the world
but take control of it if you're not
feeling good and if your
levels show even though they might show
in range but you feel like
and you're starting to notice some of
the symptoms that i've just talked about
you got to take control of it go outside
of your family doctor
and find a clinic that can help you uh
not available in every country
there's hemoglobin and hematocrit issues
so
i got my dad on on trt um
about two years ago he's 75 this year i
think something like that
so he was about 73 when he started and i
was like dad you got to try this out man
it's it's great like i feel amazing i'm
more productive i got more energy like i
was going down
he's like wow that sounds really good
you know okay so hook me up so i did
so i sent him on my doctor they scripted
him and he started doing the
injections now my dad god bless the soul
is a bit of a lazy guy
so he would do the injections but he
would basically
sit around all day watching tv drinking
a lot of tea my dad's an old british guy
so you know he likes his tea and
biscuits and like that
eating what he eats he's on a lot of
prescription meds because he had a
bypass surgery
about 15 or 20 years ago he had a heart
attack
um and um i don't know he's got like
four or five different bottles of
scripts and all this sort of stuff
and one of the things that starts to
happen for some guys on trt is your
hemoglobin your hematocrit
starts to go up because what happens is
you'll get more red red blood cells when
you've got healthy levels of
testosterone in your body
and what that does is that thickens your
blood you don't want
thick blood you don't want viscous blood
so if you ever pick up a bottle of motor
oil
like uh 20 20 w50 you can feel it's like
molasses
okay you don't want blood like that
because it because it taxes your heart
you don't want your heart working too
hard to push blood around your body
so there's a healthy range of hemoglobin
and hematocrit
and one of the things that happens when
you've got healthy levels of
testosterone
is it tends to climb up you're carrying
more red blood cells you're carrying
more oxygen in your body
which thickens your blood now there's
different things that you can do to
manage that
i've learned that you can take grape
seed extract sorry grapefruit seed
extract make sure you're properly
hydrated drinking lots of water my dad
drinks loads of tea
which is a direct so he's peeing all the
time which means he's gonna
he's not gonna be properly hot hydrated
he doesn't move enough
he would go to the gym maybe like two or
three days a week but i'll tell you this
within about six or seven months
he looked great he had way more energy
great attitude
he was losing belly fat i think he lost
something like 15 pounds
um he's about the same height as me but
he was about 225 and he lost a good
amount of weight
you know his strength went up he looked
good but his hemoglobin and his
hematocrit started to climb and his
doctor got concerned so he said you know
let's take a break for a bit
let's get you off the team let's try
some other different things he never
went back on it because
he didn't want to do the things that
were required to manage the hemoglobin
and the hematocrit
one of the things that you can do is you
can donate blood so
they'll take a pint of blood out of you
you give your alpha blood to
somebody else that needs it that's been
in a car accident or something you know
maybe you save a life
and it also thins out your blood so i've
had to donate blood from time to time
i don't need to do it so much anymore it
feels like my body sort of balanced
itself out so it's not that big of a
deal for me
um but blood donations or what's called
the therapeutic
phlebotomy which is basically they just
drain some blood and they throw in the
garbage sort of thing
the best thing to do is to donate blood
because i mean if you're on testosterone
you've got alpha you know you got
unplugged alpha blood in you you donated
to somebody that's probably been in a
car accident or going through a bypass
surgery
and they get that you know that that
high tea health healthy blood so
donating is a good way it's basically a
win-win you know
situation it helps you out it helps out
somebody else so um that's a bit of a
pain in the like going to donate
blood
maybe every three to six months or once
a year
it's a bit of a pain in the ass you got
to schedule in you got to do all their
they do the survey they prick
you then and then
you know it takes like half hour 45
minutes your time it's not particularly
convenient
but it's part of life you know if it's
something that you have to manage
there's other ways to manage it too
which i always
already described and you can do some
more research on that
you